since you've been on I had Jesse Ventura
on really yeah oh I missed that oh how
was that no no I did I I know that you
did that I did not check it out though
how was that a night it was a nightmare
he's you gotta like watch every word you
say right I mean he talked for
here it is right there he talked for
seven he took for 1700 year he took for
1700 years to hours okay
yeah it was unbelie he's like you know I
drank four look he just kept going off
he's like I drink four Locos I drink
I'll drink six Locos I'd drink four
times six I'll drink 24 Locos and I love
America so I moved to Cuba yeah or
something he's in the Baja yeah I don't
even live in the continental United
States anymore yeah
I'm in the Baja yeah that's what he said
yeah
I'm down in the Baja now
I wouldn't vote for either of them
yeah that was his whole thing bro a
two-party system is uh it's there in
place to do what it does and we're all
we're all indoctrinated he's like I
bought my American flag in uh China I
went there myself to have it it's the
largest American flag in uh in North
America
yeah he kept saying I joined the uh I
joined the Hell's Angels as well I'm
gonna you know I'm I'm part-time yeah I
just wanted free tickets to Altamonte to
see the stones and
you know back then I was just so I was
mostly following the dead and I said I
gotta go see the stones I was this far
from the guy who got stabbed in the face
I asked him I think I said hello it was
very
it was very just like barely anything
out of the gate and he just went and he
kept saying you know I gotta leave in
about I'm about to get out of here and
then he would stay for 45 more minutes
that's awesome and I hate to bash on him
but he was it was he was I can't tell if
he was mentally or just kind of getting
out there or if he was just damn had
lost you know or if he was just an
egomaniac you know yeah I mean he's he's
lived so many [__] lives I know I've
never had the opportunity to meet the
guy but anytime I watch him you know on
anything I'm just like I don't know that
I can it's one of those you don't want
to meet your Heroes kind of thing
because he is he is out there he'll go
from you know Halliburton orchestrated
the BP oil spill and then the next thing
he says is like you know what's really
good is uh we just tortillas with
scrambled eggs you said come on would
you like to sleep over I have a spare
room that you'd really like it's woodsy
I've sort of brought Minnesota to the
Baja I call it Baja soda anyway you'll
really like the aesthetic I don't know
if I [__] I don't is he gonna kill me
I can't tell if I can't stand this guy
yeah yeah I have some uh are you uh do
you ever dine on Long pig that's what
the cannibals call human being because
it tastes like pork Oh I gotta go I
gotta go in four minutes no no no stick
around I'm just getting started anyway
the Gulf of Tonga I dropped these
these mercenaries in there and I was
with the Navy Seals and of course I can
hold my breath for 19 minutes so that's
why they brought me with them they used
to they used to call me uh the snorkel
scuba yeah
the submarine
it's okay this is just like being with
him really
topic to topic oh I couldn't get a word
in I couldn't and it was the longest
interview it's a three hour interview oh
my God it was unbelievable man and we
did it like we took we kind of
commandeered this um
uh it was like a Days Inn or something
and they had a little meeting room in
there and so it was this Indian family
that like owned it so we told him you
know like this guy you know we showed
him pictures on the internet of Jesse
and like this is who's coming you know
and so the whole family was like waiting
by the door when he gave it like I don't
think they understood what was going on
I think they thought it was like a
diplomat or something but anyway he
showed up and um
the cleaning lady kept kind of trying to
sneak in and see if she could help in
any way you know just soap is hard
you have any uh Orange Crush I'd love an
orange crush let's get a couple of
orange crushes with like a three hour
he's the kind of guy I want to like lock
in a room with Alex Jones and like just
give them a bottle of uh you know
schnapps or something and see what
happens like just well they talk for
seven and a half [__] hours this is
this is unbelievable just like sleeping
yeah a golfer Tonga you know
Bohemian Grove Jesse was crazy man he
was like I was a gov I was a governor of
Minnesota I was a uh I sold sodas in uh
in Orange Grove he's like I sold sodas
and mini Governor he like would
everything started to get convoluted
like it was almost like uh there was
like a
a little something wrong in The Matrix
you know like he was getting bad Intel
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he
starts he just completely starts
glitching yeah yeah I was wrestling Bob
Backlund at the Philadelphia spec
spectrum and uh I got a call from Hugo
Chavez and really at ringside yeah and
Vince McMahon said it's you go and so
you know I uh so I hit backland uh in
the face with a chair so he could sell
it and he was outside the ring and then
I went and took the call and he said we
need you out here we need I need you to
help negotiate with Castro are these
this is even line up Time what year was
it it was 1982 when do you think it was
I don't [__] know yeah he does that
[__] when do you think yeah when do you
why don't you tell me that's what I why
well why don't you tell me if you're
such a patriot I don't know I don't know
I wasn't I was a navy suit I understand
well why don't you tell me were you
there you were there in the jungles of
Laos no you're not Laotian I thought I
read that about you on Wikipedia no I
don't what do you like do you like
orange soda or would you like it Mr Pibb
Excuse Me Miss yeah Mr pip
yeah it was unbelievable dude yeah yeah
it was the longest day though and he
just and finally at the end he's like so
I heard somewhere you're a comedian oh
geez like at at the beginning hour three
and it starts out he's like how much how
much time do you have he's like I only
have about 35 minutes or just letting
you know that after that I'm out of here
yeah like one more thing before I go and
then he just rattled off to another ash
a lot of complete this Eagle maniacal
[__] and then he said he joined the
hells hey he joined the uh he was a one
percenter right which is I guess is a
motorcycling gang will you look it up
and kudos to them dude because I think
we need more gangs in America gang gang
we need gangs yeah people are like what
gang is left even there's no more gangs
to create yeah Social Security is almost
dead that's almost that's a good gang
but it's I feel like they're losing
steam Social Security I mean I feel like
any day now people are going to start
getting just blank checks sent to them
yeah senior citizens well that's [__]
true we are very close to collapse in
every single way yeah this guy's a one
percenter that's what he said I'm a one
I'm a one percenter yeah
that's a healthy yeah he's like I've
driven Past Dead bison and uh South
Dakota I love that he didn't no so
you're a comedian yeah tell me a joke
yeah tell me oh uh I thought I thought
you were Anderson Cooper yeah I'm sorry
I'm just my meds kind of they start
balancing out around 4 35. now I can see
you're not Anderson Cooper He's like I
do Sundowners early just to get it over
with you know I [__] I do my son
Downing from three to four Thirty it was
unreal man Downing and we had to yeah it
was like it was it was on it was
unbelievable and he almost has he walks
like a Sasquatch kind of he has that
like he has that he has that former
bodybuilder like have you ever met like
someone who was like oh this guy was a
[__] in 1967 or whatever you
mean like you know former nflers and
stuff and it's like they still have that
gate yeah where it's like you're you're
67 years old but you could kick my
[__] ass like yeah you see that guy
at like the grocery store where it's
like and he's like you know just big
gnarled muscle hands and [__] like Lou
Ferrigno if you see him wow look at the
look at the ABS on he's got five ABS
there that was Lou ferrigno's that was
this that's why he could never beat
Arnold because in Mr Olympia because
Arnold had anywhere from six to eight
abs and uh Lou Ferrigno no matter what
he did he always had that Crown AB at
the top it's sort of looking over the
other abs
yeah yeah he was drinking abs and that's
why yeah that's why back then they
didn't have protein shakes you just chew
on the steak and chew on your youngest
son yeah just chew on his feet
get your nutrients as Jesse The Body in
the WWE he always had feathered things
and you know but that was also the 80s
you could Mr T with all his chains and
yeah he looked like a meth Christmas
tree I feel like Jesse Ventura yeah
that's what he reminds me yeah he just
looked like here's like it was like
Billy Idol Boy George and a giant built
guy and he's got like you know a bandana
and yeah he needs hanging from his head
yeah like where Steven Tyler kept extra
[__] you know Hey Stephen do you would
you mind if I had some of these scarves
are you using these scarves nah man go
ahead
that is unbelievable yeah the boa
God there he is with Vince McMahon were
you in the one percenters is that who
did it yeah yeah they were one percent
yeah they just [__] hated me hey man
we're out of beer what are we gonna do
with Theo how are we gonna jump him in I
got an idea we're gonna see how much
water he can drink yeah I like it good
idea let's see if he's one of us
I'll be down there in the swamps just
taking a sip every once in a while while
I'm underwater for 19 minutes wrestling
alligators and drinking swamp water
you little pansy you
see how much water you can drink
yeah so Jesse made me go drink all this
water and then I lay down on my friend's
room fell asleep and I peed and it went
Corner to Corner in the uh in the room
nice Jesse wanders in in his hoodie I've
had six four Locos I've had four or six
look I'm I've had 24 locals I just moved
to Aruba
you know when uh Costa Rica they only
have two laws I don't even know what
they are that's it's basically just a
free-for-all it's Lord of the Flies out
there I love it I built a [__] deck
that doesn't even have y beams it could
fall down at any moment I invite as many
people from the town as I can over for
tortillas with scrambled eggs just can't
wait for it to [__] fall and I'm like
ghost of evil Revolution
evil Revolution
that's how I say it
you know I was there when uh the Big
Bopper died I was right out there yeah I
saw the plane go down yeah yeah I got
out there just a minute too late because
I had to swim and I just got preoccupied
because I love being underwater and
pretty soon I'm just doing the
backstroke and then I rolled up and
Ritchie Valens is like help help yeah
yeah
hey it's you La Bamba Lou Diamond
Phillips and he said no that movie
hasn't happened yet I understand I'm
Eternal
I I cross Dimensions I've been a
governor a vampire a piss truther a
wrestler I've been here for thousands of
years I'm an angel I know you I'm an
AIDS activist
you know what that's what the you know
that's a me and Harvey Milk we wore this
this is how we you know knew each other
we were we were in politics for change
pushing pushing policy for everybody
inclusivity I was way out of it that's
why I'm in Baja trying to start a new
Society all together the two-party
system here has led us astray yeah both
of those uh geriatric freaks I wouldn't
trust either of them
and I know them both very well a lot of
people don't know this but I go duck
hunting with Joe Biden and Donald Trump
every spring because they come down to
the Baja they don't want to tell you
this they're all working for the same
Master that's right and uh we go down
there and uh
occasionally Rupert Murdoch will fly up
and everybody gets along
Tucker Cooper Anderson Cooper and Tucker
Carlson together on a tandem bicycle and
they take turns sitting in the baby seat
and Tucker's like oh
he's you know getting tickled as he's
rocking back and forth with Anderson and
everyone gets along
I did Mad TV for years and you make fun
of everybody doing silly impersonations
I've never heard from Jesse Ventura
saying don't do that yeah they had the
Tupac hologram it's a parlor trick yeah
nobody cares and it got gunned down like
two minutes and being on stage yeah
that's the other thing is right away the
one percenters show up in Biggie and uh
you know I would say soon you're outside
the Automotive Museum and it's a shug
and and uh and getting into oh no that
was Biggie that was outside at any rate
you're somewhere on Fairfax now we got
this AI thing to contend with there's
already scams happening online old
people are being targeted older people
or Boomers as the kids say they got to
kind of get out of the way or go the way
of Jesse Ventura and just you know hit
the Baja yeah hit the hit the Baja and
watch Friends on VHS
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one